non c'est pour ça que tous les grands
débats sur la l'euthanasie et tout le
reste et cetera pour moi c'est nul quand
on vient me casser les oreilles avec ça
je dis qu'est-ce que tu as fait pour la
vieille dame qui est au 6e rien alors
basta
ah pard al bonjour tu vas bien did
michelro alors Michel ZrO comment ça va
mais ça va alors depuis ce tournage du
furet oui ben ça va bien dis donc voilà
c'est pour toi trouvé du dans la non
sans blague c'est pour toi hein
regard c'est ça va voilàù on va dîner
Michel
regarde mag je va te présenter ma
nouvelle copine viens voir ah bon allez
dis dis bonjour à Michel serro regarde
bonjour Est-ce que tu est-ce que tu
aimes Michel Serot oui oui elle fait pas
elle sourit aussi est-ce que tu sais
sourire fais un beau sourire à ton
Michel
oui oui si si sais ce qu'il dit de toi
il dit ce que j'aime chez Michel serro
c'est qu'il accepte de faire tout mes
films pour pas un rond et ça je trouve
ça sympa
oui parce que dans les autes il est très
bien payé là j'ai jeté uns non non c'est
bien ils sont ils sont blagueurs ils
sont blagueurs allez venez venez allons
à la cuisine ah oui la cuisine parce que
moi je suis arrivée là ensuite hop je la
cuisine ah benah dis donc tu aimes les
couleurs hein toi ouais j'aime la
couleur allez ouis j'aime la couleur
ass-toi mich je suis arrivé la première
moi assayez-vous mets-toi là Jean-Pierre
Patricia tu reprends ta place est très
intime ouis alors voilà donc c'est
Carlos on fait on fait des Carlos Michel
bon alors il met rien de particulier
dans les dans les PL non mais simplement
ce qu'on fait c'est des dîners à thème
donc la semaine dernière c'était un
dîner orange et ce soir c'est un dîner
rose he explique-nous ce que tu mets
dans voilà les B rose ex ex cher de
torau au pom et fruits et jus de Tru à
la rose bah écoute pour moi ça va pens g
ouis ou ou bah c'estàd que comment ça se
passe on est invité ou ah oui oui ah oui
ah
invité si invité on peut participer mais
comme c'est le grand VF il vaut mieux
qu'on soit
invité tu bois quoi moi je de l'eau ah
non non non je un peu d'eau parce que tu
sais tu tournes là tu sais que je suis
aujourd'hui je me suis levé à 7h j'ai
j'ai fait des un peu de de synchro j'ai
vu un autre film que je vais voir et
cetera et là là je suis là et demain
matin je me lève à 7h c'est tu comprends
si tu veux continuer à manger
normalement simplement sans gagner des
la promo de domin là il s en ce moment
pendant qu'on est en train de on va le
regarder hein oh faut pas le
regarder c'est c'est trop triste il faut
regarder le film de on va regarder à
quoi ça ressemble mais ça s'appelle
comment le furet le furet et il joue le
rôle il est formidable parce que il a
pas la même tête que dans domin bien
entendu et pas la même tête que dans le
papillon et pas la même tête que dans
lesirondelles il il s'est fait la tête
des acteurs que nous adorons tous les
deux June Berry il il a mais c'est le
grand acteur mais avec le costume je
veux dire il a un costume de grand
acteurs et alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
viler comment il va mais vil il va très
bien d'ailleurs il est coproducteur du
ah ouais temp éur lui qui alors non
lui par leur présence déjà au départ
quand tu as vilero dans un film puis
après j'ai Renucci Patricia Dick riverse
car Z0 alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas oublier qui est
formidable il joue un rôle un peu à la
Marlon Brando à notre un vieux Truant il
est
formidable de premières minutes je suis
tombé par terre de mon SK de rire ah
ouais parce que je dis c'est pas
possible de voir un acteur en parlant de
moi je qui en fe autant mais autant dans
l'inspiration divine Jul Berry Michel
Simon rému ils en faisaient et
aujourd'hui les acteurs doivent exister
autrement que des cloches comme ça des
types ectoplasm plasmique qu'il y a dans
le cinéma français pour dire que lu ah a
plus plusre mais
voilà tiens ta bougie bien droite
hein c'est la c'est la relève de de
plein de gens de
Saturnin de Bourville et et Michel Simon
il est il est tout en même temps c'est
formidable g le père de la morandé le
compte est-ce qu'il boit de l'alcool c
est-ce qu'il boit de l'alcool je sais
pas ah mon père alors viens te faire
pardonner tous tes
péchés il y a longtemps que c'est fait s
pas de péché
hein par les 5 s ah là c'est
ça va pas doménite parce que vous allez
exploser ah non moi je
suisut alors on fait la cuisine là ouais
alors assez-vous je présente Bernard le
compte donc qui alors qui vient de faire
un bouquin assez-vous Bernard qui vient
de faire un bouquin sur le
pape ah oui ce soir tu es tombé dans un
piège bonjour toi qui un até toi qui a
un até incroyable tu es tombé dans un
piège ce soir cur il a des curtons il a
des Cau mais est un ancien lui c'est un
ancien
vra pleine d'amitié quand même vous
savez l'histoire quand même que toi tu
quand tu étais petit tu voulais être
prêtre ou clown et maintenant son rêve
c'est de devenir son rêve c'est de
devenir moine donc il veut jouer un rôle
de prêtre ah oui ça serait bien ah vous
m'en avez parlé mais voulez-vous vous ça
a été dit en confession ça non non non
un truc que je comprends pas c'est quand
tu fais dominich tu dis je veux bien
jouer dominich à condition qui de de qui
soit non coupable et quand tu fais PEO
tu sais bien que c'est un assassin
pourquoi et bien tu veux que je te
raconte brivement parce que je pas là
pour faire des conférences c'est vrai
qu'on m'a reproché par exemple de jouer
on me disait mais
vous sympathique sympathique mais je dis
vous êtes alors entre parenthèses mais
quand même il faut dire les mots vous
êtes des cons les gens qui me posaient
la question si navait pas été
sympathique ça va de so on frappait puis
il y avait une vieille dame
monsieur est-ce que docteur pouvez me
recoir recevoir mon mari Amérique du Sud
j'ai plus beaucoup de temps entrez
madame entrez madame bon mais cela dit
je j'ai montré ce qui et puis alors ce
qui est plus grave parce que je peux
quand même me défendre je joue vraiment
Peet c'est vrai mais je raconte une
hisire vous qui me parlez où est-ce que
vous étiez pendant la guerre alors me
dire oh B moi j'étais fait de la
résistance il y a toujours un mec qui a
fait de la résistance ça se trouve ça
toujours et l'autre là qui dit bon moi
j'ai pas fait de la résistance vous
étiez quoi vous étiez avez plutôt pour
les Allemands vous a fait de la vous
avez collaboré m fait que non pas
vraiment mais bon et Cera bon et puis
l'autre il vous dit ben moi qu'est-ce
que vous faisiez vous là pendant la
guerre pendant que po lui rait avec sa
chaudière et ben moi j'étais j'étais moi
j'ai rien fait de mal j'étais j'étais
j'étais je tenais un cabaret à à Pigal
et qui avait comme client ben il y avait
des y avait des il faut dire il y avait
des résistantces des mecs qui faisaient
de la résistance il faut dire il y avait
des Allemands qui venaient là aussi et
il faut dire aussi qu'il y avait des
Corses aussi ou des je sais pas quoi et
il y avait un tas de gens de et bien je
dit bravo je vous remercie maintenant
c'est une raison de plus pour
jouer ça et si pe existé c'est vous vous
avez été complice car chaque fois qu'il
y avait un problème de droite de gauche
du centre du ciel ou en bas dis donc
docteur est-ce qu'on pourrait vous
amener un paquet ce soir alors basta et
qu'est-ce qui vous a convaincu de
l'innocence alors de
d' mais parce qu'il y a aucune preuve
contre lui à partir du moment moi je
suis pas un jurist à partir du moment où
vous dit il y a pas de preuve pour le
pour le condamneré il est innocent
d'abord et en plus il se trouve que je
connais bien les gens de la terre et les
paysans ah voilà alors basta aussi me
raconte pas d'histoire c'est pas parce
que on n pas très fidèle avec sa bonne
femme et qu'on est dur avec ses enfants
et qu'on a 12 hectares et que pendant
des 75 ans on travaille pour avoir des
prunes et pour faire des
confitures c'estand est en train de se
garer ah bah qui se gare
alors
non mais tu comprends c'est
pas c'est pas suffisant pourquoi parce
que il était rude il était pas facile il
était pas très instruit mais il était
pas bête il était pas cultivé il était
comme moi pas oui c il baratinait un peu
c'est vrai ta mère étaé câau toi ouais
vous étiez baptisé pendant la guerre on
tu été baptisé non été circoncis ni
baptisé heureusement parce que sinon ou
été baptisé toi non oh là là c'est hor
Michel on s'en occuper en fait on vous
Bernard on vous a pas expliqué c'est un
dîner prosélite au cours duquel on a
décidé de
convertir on est à table mais il il y a
des sur ils vont arriver non non c'est
gérardarmand Jacob vont arriver il éta
en train de se garer il m'a
dit le voile vous êtes pour le voile
est-ce que tu pour le voile dans les Dîn
VO écoutez-moi quand j'étais jeune
j'allais à l'école avec un chapeau mou
déjà à 8 ans puis on m'a jamais viré
tu vas passer à l'olympi qu'est-ce qui
se passe oui
V au mois de mai attention faut répéter
et tout mais bien sûr que oui c'est un
grand cadre ah bah oui c'est pas la
salle des fêtes de mais pourquoi tu
attends le mois de mai mais parce que
mais parce que déjà on fait ce ce qui
nous plaît au mois de
ma voilà c'est oui pour commencer on on
va démarer on va démarrer lesger en rou
on va à la votre mes enfants on viens
viens on va te regarder il à la télé
viens non Mo je pas voir oui viens viens
Michel non mais quoi mais écoute je suis
il l' déjà je fais tout je fais beaucoup
de Ch regarde jamais att c'est énormere
am ends il est là en même temps mais
écoute je fais je fais la Converse on
très bient non je vous donnerai une
cassette si vous voulez oui moi oui
exactement mais par exemple mon épouse
elle est formidable euh moi je l'ai vu
forcément parce qu'il y a eu des des des
projections de presse
elle a pas voulu le voir parce qu'on
pvit au cinéma la technique permet sur
un grand écran elle veut le
voir à la télévision dans Lesme du petit
écran regarde ce
soir vre petite fille
regarde s j'ai bien aimé d'avoir
génération Michel Blanc ben tant mieux
tant
mieux non c'est vrai c'est terrible de
se voir non pas que je là aujourd'hui je
j'ai fait un film au mois d'OT j'ai été
le voir aujourd'hui je sais même pas
quoi en penser au il y a un certain
moment c'est fini l'émotion c'est sur le
moment de tournage après je comprends
bien ça ouais ce qui compte c'est la vie
des autres est ce qu'
ressent est-ce qu'on se voit au théâtre
mais je pense que des acteurs de cinéma
ils aiment bien se regarder ouais les
acteurs de cinéma ou th tu peux pas te
regarder mais non ça force ouais tout
recommencer comme dans la vie ça c'est
magnifique oui ça c'est
magnifique fini laisse tomber dans
ré magnifique qui peut y avoir sur une
HE et dem spectacle qui rachè tout comme
dans la vie si vous n'êtes pas très
croyant ou mal croyant ou peu croyant
vous pensez que vous êtes maître de la
vie et voilà peut être un acte de
charité aussi non parfois oui mais ce
qui m'embête c'est que on peut pas
commencer par le plus grave alors les
gens sont fixés làhaut la mort
l'eutthenasie et cetera ils sont pas
capables d'aider le copain d'un côté
alors là ça ça m'emmerde je le dis
franchement commençons par être au
béabas de la religion et puis du
christianisme et puis quand on sera sur
le notre lit de mort les uns et les
autres on verra ce qu'on a à faire alors
ça ça m'emmerde je le dis franchement
bien mich vra alors alors là les débats
ça y va est-ce que je baise est-ce que
j'aurai un gosse et je n'aurais pas
est-ce que je me fais machin est-ce que
truc je m'en fout de tout ça sortez un
peu c'est comme le gars moi écoute il y
a des choses qui me révoltent qui me
révoltent gentiment n'est-ce pas il dit
moi moi je donne je donne je donne je
donne aux gens quand je je peux je donne
je donne je pas et alors des amis à moi
des amis à moi je dire mais mais mais
Michel tu donnes où est-ce que ça va
mais je dis mon pote t'occupe pas où ça
va oui tu donnes et ça te regarde pas où
ça va sûr h va pas te demander alors le
mec il trouvve un mec dans la rue il va
demander dis donc qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire de mon argent c'est gratuit ça il
y a pas de remboursement mais Thierry
vous savez que Michel va nous faire un
cadeau merveilleux pour le soir de Noël
le 24 décembre à 19h il vient dire un
compte que j'écrit un compte de Noël
pour les SDF de la gare de Lyon oui
musée des arfin non c'est pour ça que
tous les grands débats sur la
l'euthanasie et tout le reste et cetera
pour moi c'est nul quand on vient me
casser les oreilles avec ça je dis
qu'est-ce que tu as fait pour la vieille
dame qui est au 6e rien alors basta moi
je m'en occupe c'est pas moi Michel
c'est pas moi hein c'est pas moi ah non
to je suis acteur alors je fais non mais
je je peux pas je peux je ça m'énerve
alors les mecs sont pas capables de
donner des cat sous d' une vieille dame
de un viux monsieur de s'occuper d'un
enfant ou même d'un chien parce que
j'adore les animaux et cetera mais par
contre il nous emmerde avec la la la
savoir si la pilule ou pas ou si je vais
me faire piquer au moment de ma mort
Bast c'est le bon Dieu qui s'en occupe
de ça vous sortez de vos sous sortez de
vos poches vos catre sous puis
donnez-les sans retour et commencez par
là sans retour sans retour les mec
calculent où est-ce que ça va mon P non
mais tu as raison non mais il a raison B
il a raison tu vois il met il met tout
le monde d'accord un bon prédicateur tu
V la messe
oui j'ai la messe bien sûr c'est moi je
je moi je je on m'a tellement forcé à y
aller quand j'étais petit que après je
me suis un peu dégagé de ça je suis
retourné je suis retourné non mais
sérieux c'est pas très bien produit
quand même non mais sérieux ça pas où
moi je suis un peu déçu à chaque fois on
a abandonné le côté enensang et tout le
spectacle il y a plus de spectac
nostalgie
nostalgieé un peu RAC de thier pas RAC
je vois pas pourquoi non mais je vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait pas de spectac
non le côté beauté le côté moi c'était
magnifique moi j'ai vu des ordinations
j'ai vu des ordinations Michel j'ai vu
des ordinations de prêtres h j'ai vu des
des prêtres qui sont allongés par terô
les bras en croix comme ça c'est une
beauté totale avec les petits enfants là
qui mettre l'ensemb les Orgs et tout ça
ça fait partie du truc je veux dire j'ai
revenu he c'est revenu oh c'est pas
revenu alors moi là vraiment je suis là
je suis un peu déçu quand même parce
qu'à chaque fois je me dis mais pourquoi
il dit la prière là pourquoi il fait ça
pour
Paris il y a quand même eu des abus ah
ouais c'était beau le ltin la révolution
c'est quoi c'est le concile si on passe
du latin à la langue vernaculaire mais
pourquoi parce que d'abord le latin est
une langue occidentale je vois pas
pourquoi uniquement rien vous empêche
c'est l'espéranto des Catau pourquoi
mais non vous allez en Chine on parle
pas latin je suis désolé Vietnam non
plus au nom de quoi on va culturellement
imposer le latin l'univers
entier on le impose de qu
onoseendant des siècles on a parlé latin
à l'église au nom de quoi mais
on le impose de croire que la Vierge
Marie a enfanté sans qu'il a eu machin
et tout c'est bien plus dur que le latin
avé comme
histoire V tue des gens mais il dit à
l'église dit à l'église parce qu'il y a
une église dans le
film je tue je tue tout le monde sauf
les enfants les femmes et les infirmes
voyez il a quand même il est quand même
s SLE morale voilà de ne tuer que des
[__] que des
ESP non c'est y a une morale dans ce
film c'est un film généreux c'est un
film pour pour les petites gens avec des
qui rêv à des choses magnifiques et moi
le rangard que je joue c'est il me fait
pleurer hein pathétique et en plus il
est ridicule mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez il y en a des comme ça mais il
est génialich il il est quand même il
arrive toujours à t'embarquer quand même
hein oui mais parce qu'il a un secret
avec moi comment il fait avec toi parce
qu'il arrive toujours à t'embarquer bah
il me dit écoutez voilà alors vous allez
allez jouer ça Michel je sais pas quoi
vous faire jouer parce que vous jouez
toujours pareil il commence pas à me
démolir vous êtes pas un acteur vraiment
c'est pour ce que vous êtes mais là j'ai
un TR que un truc pour vous c'est bien c
on va avoir un chapeau comme ça on va
voir près ce que vous voulez vous direz
à peu près ce que vous voudrez si vous
changez le texte ça pe rien et des dents
c'est vous avez des dents ça m'embête al
si vous pouviez enlever des motents vous
mettre du noir et vous mettre une plume
dans le cul enfin je veux dire il y a
tout écoute je crois que je peux je
faire un compliment alors j'entends des
choses tout bizarres sur Poiré Chau et
cetera dis mais c'est pas Poiré c'est
pas cro c'est ce qui se passait entre
Poiré et C c'est pas moi dans Dominici
c'est ce qui se passe avec Michel Blanc
et moi et là il y a un jeu il y a
quelque chose qui sort ça vient pas de
moi ça vient de lui et de moi le mystère
de la comédie c'est ce les échanges
entre les gens hein
oui peux pas tu peux pas pas trécher à
ce point-là où tu deviens un soliste et
tu joue tout seul alors là c'est autre
chose on va on va voir un un perroquet
ou un mec qui a une mémoire d'âne c'est
autre chose c'est mémoire d'âne d'âne
oui c'est ça qu'on
dit non mais c'est ça n'existe pas ça je
joue la cage au fol 1000 fois à peu près
et il y avait quelqu'un qui jouait une
scène là-dedans qui était une scène très
drôle du boucher il arrivait le boucheur
en disant tu prends ça ton truc là puis
on sentait que au fur à mesure il
donnait la recette il était un peu de il
était un peu
teinté dire fa tu prends ton bifte et
puis tu et puis après quand tu continues
quand c'est
cuit alors c'était c'était c'est pas moi
l'auteur c'est genamb c'était très drôle
SC qui portait magnifiqueement mais le
mec il nait qu'une scène c'estàd qu'il
m'écoutait plus du tout il descendait il
regardait le foot dans sa télé il
descendait il descendait et puis vu il
fallait qu'il il me coupait c'està dire
j'avais même pas le temps de respirer il
enchaînit il il n'écoutait pas ce que je
lu disais et un jour parce que je suis
pas méchant mais ça m'a au bout d'un
moment quand je sens qu'il y a une bonne
scène qu'elle est mal joué ça me fait
chier quand même alors je dis euh je lui
dis en Contin ilement de jouer dans le
personnage je lu dis écoute c'est pas
grave tu parles trop vite h devant les
gens
ouais devant les gens les gens nont pas
je faisais avec un tel culot en jouant
le personnage toujours j'ai pas dit
écoute on me fais chier et cetera non je
dis tu parles tu parles trop vite je te
jure simplement tu me
regardes tu me regarde quand je te pose
la question tu respires et tuécoutes et
puis tu me réponds mais c'est pas grave
cocotte puisque je jouais mon c'est pas
on on va le refaire on l'a refait en
scène ça comme ça et bien j'avais un tel
culot ça dépasse mes intentions les gens
se sont aperçus de rien ils ont cru que
c'était dans la
pièceard oui comment tu vas la jouer là
le personnage de de [__] dur là je
sais pas encore très bien mais tu peux
pas la jouer comme ça tu peux pas comme
ça mais tu peux pas le faire comme ça
aujourd'hui tu le fais plus comme
ça l'homo tu es comme tu le faisais dans
dans la cage au fol c'est fini ça il y a
25 ans ou je sais pas quoi CIT ça
n'existe plus c'est fini nous on a connu
ça parce que dans les cabarets on a
connu un T de gens c'est l'antiire quoi
c'est le sket de l'anti on commencé en
fait la cage au fol ça vient du sket
l'anti absolument mais maintenant
maintenant les personnages que nous on
faisait n'existent plus il y avait des
références forcément avec je sais pas
chez tonton tu as connu tout ça ton ou
oh là là c'était formidable chez Michou
aussi non et alors mais c'était très
troublant parce
que on avait beaucoup de visites de de
gens qui venaient dans les loges je et
au au départ on on avait été je veux
dire tous les homos de Paris que il y
avait des copains làdedansain ils
étaient contre le principe parce qu'il
dit ils vont se [__] de nous oua ils
vont se [__] de nous CIT chaud il y a
plein de mecs qui venaient te voir en
disant il faut pas le faire ah oua il
faut pas le faire non seulement mais des
gens qui nous parlaient plus des copains
ouais et puis euh au fur et à mesure
qu'ils ont ils ont vu ce qui se passait
c'està dire que c'était euh il trouvait
pas ça ridicule ouais
et moi j'ai dans ma loge des gens qui me
disaient passer une soirée
formidable extraordinaire et quand il se
met en rose et quand il se met en rose
lu dis tu es tuas encore mieux en bonne
femme qu'avec ton veston et cetera céit
mouvant cétait de la Noë tu sais
pourquoi c'était bien c'était parce que
beaucoup d'humanité beaucoup beaucoup de
oui mais tu sais qu'ors que on sait pas
par exemple c'est que en Italie puisquil
y avait t un gros succès et bien le
succès c'est'est pas fait sur l'énormité
la drôlerie mais sur l'émotion ouais et
les gens pleuraient peut-être oui mais
toi tu le faisais très comme ça aussi ou
c'était l'autodérision oui non puis il y
avait un côté pas tout des rision
c'était c'était la situation impossible
à vivre et un drame extraordinaire que
le mec qui VI on va recevoir le fils
mais il faut que tu te mettes en
bonhomme parce qu'on veut pas on va pas
dire qu'on est alors l' dit ben je peux
aussi m'abiller comme un homme ouis
sabillit comme un homme il met mais il
gardait des chaussettes roses des trucs
comme ça alors c'était pathétique
c'était c'était c'était vrai c'était
humain et c'est pour ça que ça touchait
les gens mais tu sais que même quand je
fais le clone au CIRC il y a des moments
de vérité qui qui sont payants hein faut
pas tricher et et vraiment quand je dis
en blague à un jeune comédien ce que tu
c'est ce qui va t'apper éce dans le film
viens voir Gérard viens IR il est
vachement bien pourquoi tu veux pas te
voir je comprends pas oui il faudrait
vous voir venez avec nousz voir c'est
fini d'ailleurs venez on va vous voir
mais on s'en fout je vous fer les yeux
venez-vous voir c'est pas vrai ce que je
dis ou quoi je dis des conneries ou quoi
non non super c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
je je sais pas trifer alors voilà c'est
ça qui est merveilleux chez vous il faut
aller dans la chambre allez venez Michel
venezenez Michel VZ oh là là alors vous
savez que j'ai perdu mon mon frère
ouièère 90 ans dit oh là là vous étiez à
l'enterrement
mais
alors on voit que Michel Blanc je te dis
je me
demande ce que tu as foutu dans Oh mer
c'est une connerie ça mais tu y es pas
tu y es pas mais non je suis pas mais tu
y es pas c'est pas pour ça que je pleure
NAS plus rien à faire ici alors tu t'en
vas
maintenant tu sais bien qu'il faut que
j'entre à Paris c'est la fin de la
première partie d'accord ouais ouis
pourquoi tu m'emmènes pas avec toi hein
c'est mexpliquerai quel projet de
théâtre sur la B me rejoindre la ba poug
pouger je te promets j'ai du mal à
trouver les sous
[Musique]
moi je vous verrais mieux quand
mêmeich il est bien Michel c'est les de
orphelines que Michel c'est pas l'acteur
dont vous parliz lui non c'est pas
l'acteur don par celui quicoute pas
c'est qui
celui- plusard grandère vous inquiétez
pas votre tour
viendra 10 devant le juge maintenant tu
as vraiment plus de figure je te
jure gust il y a une différence entre et
les autr comme tu l'as trouvé sur le
corps ouis il a une drôle de différence
hein on voit COP puis les autres à côté
on dirait des mais c'est pas la même tu
as fini dire du mal mais c'est pas la
même chose vais vous triompher làdedans
regardez le sûr certain bien ce que je
pensais elle vient de chez mais VI chez
nous mais j'eni pas de carabine chez moi
ah oui ah qu'est-ce que tu as été
inventé encore hein vous voyez pas qu'il
V notre peau bon je veux tout le monde
demain matin à mon bureau Clovis zé
enfin tout le monde
[Musique]
quoi toi tu es d'accord avec la thèse de
du film là que c'est les services
secrets oui tu penses oui oui c'est un
espion ah
ouisou ce que dire un règlement
c'est la cartonné ça non c'est la marché
ça non des millions moi je dis que ça
fera des
millions non plus que Star Académie tu
crois ou oh je sa pas sûr je connais pas
bien les scores des uns et des autres
merci c'est des
personnes salut merci he au revoir
Michel on s'appelle pour les audiences
de Dominici
ok 38 salut et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater deard tube abonnez-vous et mettez
un pouce
bleu